tutti ragazzi benvenuti a questo video
sono felice oggi siamo su file rated
jean baker ragazzi che sarebbe final
eight spongebob che tra l'altro è molto
felice ce lo vedete che proprio non
fatemi domande ragazzi ho provato vedere
come ciao ma stai zitto sono le grafiche
ragazzi è venti volte meglio phinet
freddy's non so perché quindi devo
chiudere le porte per bene ok quindi non
devo fare arrivare nessuno dentro la
stanza bene fin qua ci era arrivata da
ero a sponge spingi spingi le case ma
carissimo patrick è vero ma dov'è
salve non siamo interessati ai venditori
porta a porta però grazie nel normale
che mi sia spuntato sport ma c'è ancora
c'è ancora regala abbiamo spongebob che
è uno sfogo molto depresso abbiamo
patrick che è un gran figo dove è
patrick caos mangi hai fatto balestra
zio sticazzi equa queste patrick per
l'emozione cosa sta a farsi st
masturbando toni che cazzo ci fai
phinet spongebob mancandolo ai ragazzi
ce la possiamo farcela stiamo facendo
anzi non so come tolta zio e non hai una
bella cera che c'è la schiena curva c'è
mal di schiena ma per il mal di schiena
al momento veniamo una medicina
no ragazzi è la cosa più è sparito
porca di quella trottola lurida spugna
della minkia palo ragazzi ci riprova è
andata male perché è andata male ma ce
la posso fare patrick uccio bello dov'è
che cazzo estero trovate mi patrick
immediatamente ragazzi vi prego ma può
attaccarmi solo spongebob oppure gli
altri amico mio bello lo so che stai
guardando un porno frega
non fanno il giorno non sono io il porno
non sono io questo vuole il mio culo
ragazzi lo vedo dalla faccia bene non ho
capito ma non importa ragazzi
l'importante che non entri sponge però
devi stare calmo devi star calmo ti
porto un ceffone che modo ti giro la
testa patrick che bella cera che ci hai
guarda un po adesso chiudiamo la porta
bene dopo più di tre mesi di pura
vacanza e poi ti segue pure la pula
humble evo giocare a final eight
freddy's ma dimmi un po chi se lo in cui
se sto così con le porte chiuse senza
che nessuno entri mai nella vita
spiegatemi come fanno a prenderlo da
presa per il culo ragazzi c'è per forza
che non è possibile però non capito qual
è ma c'è ancora
proponiamo a patrick un lavoro diver
chrome è un figo lo vedo figo lo vedo
ben preso dai forza 11 10 veloce veloce
io chiudo io chiudo chiedo come frega
niente
chiudo sucate 3 2 1 se ce l'ho fatta
ragazzi è stato intensivo ma veramente
tanto contento estro lo vedi questo
mirano tutto nel culo dai che siamo
partiti bene tu hai rotto i [ __ ] non
sono anche chi sei fotte sega lazio dove
l'altro zio dove l'altro zio dove
l'altro zio dove l'altro zio altro zio
zio di lo zio zio zio di zio zio zio
ecologia sapete ragazzi vi svelo un
segreto che potrebbe essere una cosa
pesante non fregherà un cazzo a nessuno
però io non ho mai seguito tanto
spongebob non so non lo conosco per bene
lo che uno schizzo caselli che gira un
kebab l'esempio questo non so chi cazzo
si ha però è un figo
se un chiamare pizzaiolo che ci porta la
pizza novero svolgi la voi quattro
formaggi batteri pomodoro sono più canto
ma oggi qui porti via manci qui poco
vodka traiano porta via
sapevo che in qualche modo ma infila una
capra anzi se chiedevo tutte e due le
porte magari ci riproviamo cioè una roba
oscena spiegatemi serata ciò che è
quindi però non sembra un cazzo squibb
non ci somiglia manco per il bene dove è
andato ragazzi dove è andato e ora tutti
calmi calmi tutti tutti i cani che chi
ieri iuri chechi calmi no no mi incazzo
credo c'entri qualcosa questo non
c'entra un cazzo che cos'è sta roba
spiegato voglio delle spiegazioni a meno
quello che fa c'era
anch'io ma [ __ ] per quei ragazzi
ci voglia di spiegarmi cosa devo fare
beni che passano i condotti sto stronzo
abilmente arriva arriva qui e devo
chiude ma dai ma di te lo straccio ho
capito tutto fermi
eccolo qui bastardo so che ho fatto
incastrare pure nel tentare pro bastardo
via dalle palle 6 chiuso chiuso dove di
questo sei chiuso
no ovvio no no no no no no no no no no
no no ok ho avuto per un attimo terrore
che padre che mi saltasse addosso
fantasti se n'è andato ce l'ho fatta
dov'è andato donna ex pace patrick ok ok
perfetto perfetto perfetto no squiddy
nos qui no no no no per la seconda notte
almeno la seconda fatemela superarvi
prego se patrick i lo vedo lì vuol dire
che poi arriva qua bastardo bastardo
pezzo sponge bob è diventato un microbo
che cosa fa o che è successo ma no non
ci credo non è possibile mancavano venti
secondi di made in no regala 20 secondi
no ti ammazzo le famiglie tutte e due di
nos qui di nos quindi torna indietro
torna indietro mi incazzo è mi incazzo
torna indietro mica fare dietrofront
ti apro io qua tiro aperto adesso te ne
vai te ne vai te ne stai andando madonna
se mi salta tutto
se mi senti ti uccido te lo dico ti
prendo schiavi
minchiate il cazzo detto ma [ __ ]
stai lì perché madonna giu lo chiama la
polizia
il cuore a mille ce la posso più fare
fermo lì c'è chi denuncia
chiudo è ovviamente sta lì e chiudo
questa 98 76 54
[Musica]
che botta di culo assurdo basta ragazzi
ne voglio più sapere
andate a morire tutti e tre bruciati
inglobati in un'orgia è stato
bruttissimo voglio più vedere nella mia
vita per non fare il terzo ovviamente
ragazzi sto scherzando perché lo farò
nel prossimo episodio e meno stanotte
lasciatemi dormire quindi ragazzi lascio
che svolgi concluda quell'episodio e
cosa sento seguito è piaciuto al salto
momento mi piace anche a pagina di
facebook e con il lido trattenere
estinzione o mi piace per sponge che
sempre più contento per ogni mi piace il
suo sorriso tornerà terroristi discreti
ci vediamo al prossimo vinto dai ragazzi
[Musica]